[Music]
all right everyone hello and welcome
back to
another episode of the road to 2000 uh
tonight i wanted to
take you guys through uh some really
really fun games
that ended uh quickly uh
due to an attack that was launched with
either g4 or
g5 uh straight from the opening and i
wanted to talk a little bit about the
conditions
that you need to play a move like g4 so
early on
and how it worked in these games and uh
when hopefully you can try to do it in
your own games
for you know just just a fun quick
attack
from the opening uh and
what made me want to do this lecture is
actually
this game that was very very recently
played
in the legends of chess tournament that
is currently going on on chess 24
and this was of course a game between
magnus carlson and anish geary
so the game started off fairly normally
with d4
knight f6 c4 e6
knight f3 it's quite fashionable to
avoid the nimzo indian these days
d5 knight c3 bishop b4
officially arriving at the regozin and
then magnus played the most popular move
bishop g5 black played the move h6
attacking this bishop this is pretty
much the main line here
and now there's a few different options
that white can choose
a lot of players after bishop g5 are
willing to part with bishop after bishop
takes f6
queen takes f6 and after e3 or queen a4
check or
any number of moves you're going to get
a fairly normal game for the ragozan
where white trades off this bishop for
the knight to alleviate some pressure on
this knight on c3
no knights jumping into e4 and it's
gonna be a fairly simple
uh you know type type of game it's not
gonna be the crazy complex
attacking games that we're looking for
tonight so magnus
came up with a very very interesting
move it's safe to call it a
novelty here uh rather than take on f6
or do the also fairly natural bishop h4
magnus actually retreats this bishop all
the way back to d2
and this is definitely a unique
idea by magnus here so i wanted to turn
it over to the chat
what would you do with the black pieces
after bishop d2
let's see if you're going to uh sort of
fall into the same kind of trap
that anish giri did in this game what
looks natural
to you with the black pieces here
yes hello hello to everyone in the chats
not
unfortunately a grab tutorial uh be on
the lookout for that
at a later date although i could hardly
compete with jonathan schranz's
grav video that he's already made
hello chess king so
there are a few different choices here
and
yo-yo in the chat is saying c5 and this
is probably a really good idea for black
just challenging the center as quickly
as possible
other moves you can you could consider
are knight b to d7
and of course the move castles which
michael keating uh has actually
suggested in the chat
uh the move knight e4 doesn't quite work
because knight takes c4 would be quite
strong
when this knight is actually defending
the bishop on d2
uh knight e4 is a great idea when the
knight is still pinned to the king
but with the bishop on d2 this move
actually just strictly prevents the move
knight e4
and in the game geary chose to move
castles which
you know itself is not a mistake
but it was definitely sort of what
magnus carlsen
was hoping for so let's see if you guys
know how to read
if you guys know how to read the title
you'll be able to guess white's next
move
of course magnus in this position
launched an attack
with the move pawn to g4 and
what allows magnus to play this move
here well there's a few different
conditions
that have been met already that sort of
make the uh
make the timing right for this g4 push
so what conditions are those well number
one black has king's side castled
that means it is fairly sensible to
launch an attack on the king's side
where black's king is
number two of course white has not
castled you wouldn't see magnus playing
like this if his king was sitting on g1
and number three magnus has managed to
provoke this move h6
this is why we saw magnus bring the
bishop out to g5 and then back to d2
uh there is the potential here to just
play the move
bishop d2 directly of course this has
actually been played before in fairly
high level chess
but with bishop g5 and bishop d2
now magnus is giving himself this extra
option of g4
in the event that black castles so
why does h6 matter well if you've seen
my lecture on hooks you'll know exactly
what i'm talking about
it means that these attacks with g4
followed by g5 are going to actually
come
with pretty significant threats here if
g5 is allowed to be played
then magnus can immediately capture on
the h6 pawn
and in doing so will very easily open up
files
in front of the black king
so all of that is to say the timing is
right here
for g4 and the point of this lecture is
one to
to really enjoy these nice attacking
games but two
i want to make sure you guys kind of
understand why g4 is playable here
and not playable in most positions it's
a very specific sort of
uh circumstance however it is a
circumstance that appears quite often
so when black castles has the move h6
included
and white of course has not castled that
might mean the timing is right for this
g4 push and we're going to look at
this showing up in actually a variety of
different
openings here where white can attack
with an early g4 or blackened attack
with an early
g5 so all of that is to say magnus
plays g4 here and then giri dove
into quite a bit of a think this was of
course
a 15 minute game with some increment and
gary spent
about five minutes so about a third of
his time choosing his next move
very very carefully a game in legends of
chess
where there was g4 well chess king i
think we are looking at that game
uh this is what actually gave me the
idea for the lecture
so we're starting off with the game from
legends of chess
uh and then the choice that gary came up
with was actually just
to capture on c3 and after bishop takes
c3
gary wanted to plant this knight onto e4
and this was a perfectly fine way of
playing for geary and the fact of the
matter is
objectively after g4 it's not as if
magnus has a crushing advantage
uh his advantage is that he's looked at
this before
and he knows how to attack with the
white pieces here
whereas giri is sort of just playing
this over the board
so this is the type of move that you can
definitely keep in your back pocket
uh to surprise some opponents
other choices for geary were definitely
to just develop normally with a move
like knight bd7 you can even play a move
like rook
e8 if you so desire giving this bishop
some retreating squares
or even c5 is totally playable counter
attacking in the center
knight takes g4 might be a little bit
much because the move rook g1
is sort of playing into white's hands a
little bit you don't really want to
uh be facing these sort of threats quite
so early on
for example this is probably already
just strictly winning material
although 98 might be playable once again
this is going to be a good pawn
sacrifice
for white in the game though we saw
takes on c3 and 94 which is perfectly
fine
and now magnus plays a move you might
not expect
rather than the the slightly more
natural h4 he plays the move queen c2
and so why does magnus carlsen play the
move queen to c2 here
rather than go straight into the attack
with a move like h4
while he's actually looking to improve
upon the move h4
by doing things just a little bit more
quickly
how is that going to be possible well we
will actually see very very quickly how
that is in fact
going to be possible yes also he wants
to castle queen side so queen c2 does
pave the way
for queen side castles and moves the
queen into an attacking position
of course this is all great stuff but
the point is
magnus is purposefully delaying the move
h4
as well geary very naturally attacks in
the center with the move c5
we see d takes c5 by magnus carlson
opening up this bishop as well into the
attack
and then geary plays the move b6 which
is very very natural once again he just
wants to take back on c5
uh he is not expecting magnus to capture
on v6
as after a move like ab6 or queen b6
uh it's actually going to be geary with
some pressure on the queen side
so uh here magnus carlsen plays
the move uh that
successfully launches his attack with
the most
tempo it goes the fastest now uh for
magnus carlsen so i'd like to ask you
guys at home
to try and come up with uh with magnus
carlson's next move here
what do you think magnus carlsen played
in this
position
chess king says h4 yo-yo
says g5 and actually yo-yo is gonna be
correct here so like i was saying magnus
is
purposefully delaying the move h4
and the reason for that is because he
wants to play g5 actually first
now how does this make any sense well
it's actually going to be
breaking through even faster than if
magnus had played h4
you can think of it like this if magnus
carlsen plays h4 here
geary now has time to take back on c5
and his counter play is coming one move
faster right you spent a tempo on
h4 and geary gets to spend a tempo
taking back on c5
and like i said counter play is coming
faster
whereas if you start with g5 now after
the move h takes g5
and you follow this up with h4 all of a
sudden geary does not have the time to
retake
on c5 because you're taking back on g5
and opening up the h file so you see how
magnus kind of gains a tempo
by playing g5 first before h4
now this isn't always going to be the
correct thing to do
but in this case i think this is really
a clever idea
and it's one to keep in mind when you're
attacking with a g pawn like this
sometimes it's better to play uh g5
directly
and follow it up with h4 to do things
with the utmost
you know urgency with the most tempo
possible
in the game of course geary did not
allow magnus to open
the h file and the downside to playing
uh g5 before h4 is that now
by not recapturing immediately the g
pawn does get to live
so in the game geary plays the move g4
and yes uh vuk has
the right idea magnus's idea after g4
was now that he gets to use the h pawn
to plant the knight on g5
and uh he's actually correct in thinking
that this
was not the correct way to play for
geary
geary's actually allowed magnus a little
bit too much activity now with
his pieces coming into the g file coming
in on the h
file and magnus already i believe has a
winning advantage
so where was the improvement for
uh for black well after g5
uh perhaps it would have been a little
bit more prudent to in fact play the
move h5
and this would be a better try as vuk in
the chat is saying
now though i do think magnus could take
the time to recapture on b6
and play a move like e3 and the
difference here
is that magnus is not down a pawn and
his attack
is still coming you know quite fluidly
uh the move bishop g2 is playable
and the the game will just kind of
continue from here magnus is going to
have a little bit of pressure
on this d-pawn as well and you can sort
of just go back into normal chess
territory here you don't necessarily
need
to be playing as if it's checkmate or
bust on the king's side
other moves you can expect are things
like rook g1 to come on
at a later date with ideas of playing g6
and
like i said magnus sort of taking over
on the d4 square
that's just one more way the game could
have gone in the game though
h takes g5 was played by giri now after
h4 g4 knight g5 uh
gary's only move here to try to save the
game is actually f5
no way you can actually capture this
knight opening up the h file
when this is just going to be totally
disastrous for black
so f5 played in the game and now magnus
stays cool under pressure
does not kind of go crazy here and just
develops his piece with bishop g2
and this is perfectly fine uh white
still has a
pretty sizable advantage here now b
takes c5 has to be played by geary he
needs to counter attack
in the center
so yeah g5 h5 might have made a little
bit more sense because
in the game uh rather than having a pawn
on g5 magnus got to bring this knight to
g5
and that's kind of the attacker that's
uh
broke the camel's back sure
uh meaning that this is the the
important piece that allows magnus to
really break through successfully here
you know h5 was just a little bit more
uh
was just a little bit better we'll say
at keeping files closed
and keeping the pieces out of the game
because then white still has to actually
deal with having this g
pawn on g5 okay now in the game
magnus very naturally queen side castles
and
geary gets a little bit impatient here
and actually does capture on g5
and this turns out to be sort of the the
fatal mistake
after knight takes g5 the game is is
pretty much over magnus carlsen just
wins
a better try would have been the move
knight c6
when uh magnus can just start taking
free stuff on d5
and even a move like e3 here just keeps
all of the options open now for uh
for white alternatively if you try
capturing stuff
unfortunately this isn't gonna quite
work because the move bishop f5 is gonna
be strong
uh but just a normal looking position
now
for uh for magnus even the move e3 first
keeping the tension here is definitely
going to be playable
uh and actually yeah no you you can just
win material straight off the bat
with uh with this sort of line
uh now gary would get to play d4 here so
i don't know if you actually want to
allow this
but this definitely would still be
advantageous for magnus
so knight c6 would have been a better
try knight takes g5
now we simply take back after queen
takes g5 really any way to block this
check wins
magnus simply plays the move king b1 and
now after knight d7
there's just no way to guard against all
the threats coming through
on d5 if you try something like knight
c6
we still take knight b4 we can just take
this
and even the move d6 here is winning
although
moves like queen c6 are also going to be
winning
uh maybe even a little bit faster i mean
d6 take this guy
win the game you know etc etc
so knight d7 was gary's try magnus takes
on d5
and now knight b6 was the point if d
takes e6 and bishop takes e6
and magnus goes up the exchange with a
winning advantage
the game did continue with queen d2 and
geary maybe should have gone for the
exchange down end game
uh likely it's just dead lost but you
know it was probably a better try
than queen g6 when black's king is going
to be significantly weaker
than white's king queen d6 played in the
game
f4 check king a1 rickf8 and now i'd like
to give a tactics puzzle to you guys in
the chat or at home
uh white to move and win here
what do you think white to move and win
also while you think about that i came
prepared tonight got myself some water
we're ready to go
water pouring class fun stuff
and yeah chess king has it uh it's just
a simple checkmate with the move ricky
chad
king takes a chap queen takes f8 check
king h7
h1 check queen h6
and then we actually have a checkmate
thanks to the pin on the queen
so uh in the game magnus actually did
end up missing this and the game
continued for a while
but the important part has kind of
passed uh g3 was played
and here once again queen takes c5 would
be nice with the idea of the same
checkmate but queen h5 instead
and after a few more moves we saw richie
one
takes takes and here geary decided
to give up the game as this is just a
hopeless hopeless ending
uh really not much to be done here these
two puns are totally gonna win the game
after i don't know something something
like this even
uh it's as simple as it gets so yeah he
he missed the mate in four actually
missed the mate and four
uh okay so what were the key points of
this game
well obviously the point of the lecture
is this move g4
and the conditions were just right for
magnus to go ahead and play this move
black had castle king's side had
committed to the move h6
and white was still keeping very very
flexible
uh in this game so all right i want to
take
a look at a fairly different type of
position now
and you might say yeah okay yeah this g4
stuff it's great for rapid chess
but i mean come on nobody's playing like
this uh you know
in real chess games and to those of you
who say that
i would like to introduce you to the man
named vladimir kramnik
in the 2018 candidates tournament no
less
uh so this is the best of the best this
is where
uh the players bring their absolute a
game their best openings possible
and try to show something uh in
the candidates tournament for that shot
at the world title
so let's see how it went uh in the game
kramnik was playing against levon
aronian lavon with the white pieces
chose e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 we have bishop b5
knight f6 going for the berlin now d3
and bishop c5 by black lavon
went for this exchange on c6 we have
takes takes
castles and now uh this pawn is attacked
so queen e7 by kramnik and here
lavonne makes a bit of a mistake
now levon plays the move h3 and
those of you familiar with the first
game might be able to tell me
you know what is starting to become a
good idea
in this position and uh lavon of course
has had
very rocky candidates tournaments uh
ever since he has been
at the top of the game and in this one i
believe he was just
uh he was pretty new to playing the move
one e4
he had been a 1d4 player for most of his
life and so perhaps this mistake comes
from a little bit
of an experience but here actually
more than in the first game black does
have a significant advantage
so of course after castles
and h3 committing to both of these moves
when black has still
maintained uh such flexibility when
queenside castles is still definitely a
real option
for black now uh this is going to be a
bit of a mistake
in fact white should not commit to this
move h3 and should just develop this
knight normally
and then the game is going to continue
under fairly normal lines
like like this perhaps even knight c4
and even here sometimes queen side
castles gets played
but more often is knight d7 and the game
is just going to continue
pretty normally with black eventually
castling king's side as well
what's the difference here well here
black has not committed this bishop out
to g4
black has not you know wasted any time
and
now black can successfully launch his
attack so how do we go about doing it
because h
or g5 immediately is actually going to
be
very advantageous in fact for white uh
white can simply take this pawn
you know we play move like rook h rook
g8 but now king h1
and we're not really getting too far
with this attack right sometimes
a pawn is a pawn sometimes a pawn is
upon even queen d2
is maybe slightly more more accurate
here
uh so we need to be a little bit more
clever than g5 so yeah beltran has the
right move
you have to start with the move rook g8
now why do we want to start with rg8
instead of h6
well once again it's all about
saving as much time as possible in these
king side attacks it's about doing
things
you know with the most pace as you can
so with h6
you know let's say c3 sure you can play
the move g5
but later you're going to want to play
the move h5 so there's actually no
reason to play the move
h6 because you would like to bring this
pawn to h5
in one step that's why rook g8 is the
move that vladimir kramnik shows
in this game now levon
was anticipating the move g5 a huge
problem for white
after g5 is that uh
if you ever take this guy now there's
bishop takes h3 immediately
as well as h6 followed by bishop takes
h3 and the point is this king is a
little bit stuck
opposite the rook so it makes sense for
lavon to play to move king h1
as he did in the game now
once again rather than play h6 to
prepare g5
uh kramnik tries to do things as quickly
as possible so rather than spend the
tempo
on h6 he spends the tempo by playing
knight h5
the point being he's bringing this
knight into attacking position
as well as supporting the g5 break with
the queen now c3 was lavon's choice
trying to fight back in the center but
g5 is coming very very very quickly
very very very very quickly in fact
uh now with c3 lavon was actually
preparing a bit of a tactic
with knight takes e5 so i'd like you
guys
at home to pause just a moment here
see what you want to do about this move
knight takes e5 what's the idea
here for uh for kramnik
yeah the chat thinks they remember this
game it was a pretty famous one
like i said it happened in uh the
previous candidates
tournament so it did make some waves
uh so chess king the problem is queen
takes e5
is too slow you know we don't want to
waste our time
dealing with things in the center these
king side attacks
are all about speed absolutely all about
the speed
and if we take the time to take on e5
well white can simply take this knight
on h5 and now the move g4 is going to be
a bit of a mistake
and so with this type of stuff our
attack is very much being slowed down
you know d4 uh moves like e5 also come
to mind
and white is going to be doing a lot
better than he kind of deserves
in this specific scenario maybe e5 is a
bit much
and white can just start bringing pieces
back to the defense on the king side
so rather than take on e5 no kramnik
plays g4 immediately and and yeah this
is the right idea
you just go go go go go try and
checkmate the guy as
quickly as possible uh now
if white tries to capture this pawn he's
in
for uh quite a bit of trouble here
with queen h4 check and knight g3 taking
advantage of this pin
as well so uh levon aronian starts with
the move d4 which is correct
this bishop has to retreat now to d6 and
now once again taking this guy is not
really to be advised
uh because once again it's
a different checkmate this time around
so after bishop d6 levon aronian plays
the move g3
trying his utmost to keep things closed
on the king's side
now we do see bishop takes e5 getting
rid of this knights
d takes e5 and queen takes e5 and now
after queen d4
uh of course kramnik here isn't really
interested in trading the queens
so he drops the queen back to e7 and
now levon ironian successfully closes
things up
with h4 so my question now is guys
uh it looks as though levon aronian
has really successfully shut things down
on the king's side
for the moment so what happens next
you know i feel like a lot of players
attacking with the black pieces here
would start to feel a little bit
disheartened once h4 appears on the
board
because it's really not clear how we get
at this king from now on
so you guys at home how do you want to
continue this game
how do you want to continue
yeah to bring the rest of the pieces but
but where are you bringing them
right you know bringing the pieces into
the attack is great
but you want to be doing it with some
ideas in mind you want
you know some kind of idea in mind like
knight takes g3
uh is is pretty bad right but you know
it'd be like an idea
right knight f4 maybe would be like an
idea so you want to bring the pieces
over
but you want to do it with some kind of
idea in mind
try to use the leak the weak light
squares so what does this mean
yeah okay everybody is saying like bring
the pieces in but that's
that's not really enough in this type of
scenario you can't
can't just try to bring the pieces in
you want to
bring them in with some idea of a future
break
that you want to make so yeah usama has
a really great idea
and that idea kind of goes in tandem
with what yaroslav was saying as well
and that's the weak light squares right
uh white has very much weakened the
light squares
by uh these pawn moves to keep things
closed on the king's side
so now rather than kind of beat her head
against the wall trying to
you know like i don't know double rooks
on the g file or something
we can start aiming for the move f5 as
usama
is uh is saying now of course we
wouldn't want to play this move
immediately because our king
is rather stuck in the center here these
types of threats
are going to be a little bit difficult
so first
kramnik tries to displace the queen but
i do think it's really important
to kind of understand what it is we're
hoping to accomplish
with our pieces rather than sort of just
blindly bringing the pieces into the
game
so immediately kramnik plays a really
great move and that move is c5
it's just to displace this very active
queen which was
causing some very serious threats the
queen
went on over to c4 kramnik develops with
tempo with bishop b6
we have queen b5 check and now c6
and the queen steps on back to a4 uh
but now actually this is sort of a
fatal mistake for lavonne he needed this
queen
back around the king's side around the
center to help
aid in the defense now on a4 it's doing
a good job of preventing
queen side castles but you guys have
actually already found
the winning idea here of course that
move is to play
f5 and f5 was played in the game
now of course if captures you are
actually now
in fact asking for knight takes g3
bishop d5 check
and queen e2 when this is just
devastation on the king's side
uh so knight takes g3 did get its day in
the sun as well
so of course white cannot actually
capture this and even if you don't see
knight takes g3
this is going to be a pretty good
advantage here
for black regardless playing a move like
c4
just keeping the queen out of the game
and making threats on the
king's side although the move knight
takes g3 is really the only move
that absolutely wins here so f5
great move by kramnik and now uh
somebody mentioned earlier that they
thought bishop g5 was a threat and this
is what was played in the game
so how do you want to respond to bishop
g5 chatram
how to respond to bishop g5
yeah of course without hesitation you
should
be capturing this bishop on g5
this is sort of your opportunity to open
the h file
and get even more avenues into the black
or the white king side
so h takes g5 was played in the game and
now
once again showing accuracy queen takes
g5 is going to be a winning position
here
but kramnik finds even better with the
move f4
just immediately crashing through onto
g3 queen d1 was played in the game
rook d8 activating the final piece queen
c1
now fg3 and if recaptures just knight
takes g3
is good enough so knight a3 was played
in the game
uh but now rook d3 and the the final
pieces
are sort of uh lurking around the white
king
rook d1 was played sorry rook d1 was
played network e1
and now bishop d5 is the spectacular
finish to this game
uh f3 was played trying to defend but
now g takes f3
and after e takes d5 the move queen e2
rookie one and g2 check was enough
for lavonne to resign this game uh even
though the black queen
is pinned uh it's not going to help here
as ms king is going to get corralled
uh if king h2 we take the rook
if king h1 we give this check
and then f1 queen is a pretty
spectacular checkmate
not often you see this many major pieces
around the white king
but here we do see it uh okay
so once again the story of this game
is this move rook g8 and
actually the story of this game is this
move seven
h3 so already from move seven we see
black
aiming for this g5 idea
uh and
even if you're not comfortable using
this type of attacking maneuver in your
own games
it's very very important to be aware of
it for this exact reason
because the moves lavon played were very
very natural moves there was nothing
really out of the ordinary for what
lavon is doing
and if you're gonna be caught totally
off guard as lavon was in this game
by these ideas it's really important to
to
actually be considering like hey wait a
second you know i've i've already
castled my opponent hasn't i'm playing
moves on the king's side
is is is this gonna just kind of crush
me and in this case
it turns out that rick g8 is a very very
good move
for black as kramnik demonstrated in
this game
wow that's awesome to hear it matthias
glad
glad to hear it's helping
glad to hear it's helping
yeah great wolf is saying he would have
had hesitation with sacrificing the
exchange on g5 but
i think you get there eventually
in what cases is the g5 g4 idea not a
good response to h3
h6 well it really does depend
right taking a look at this case this is
really one of the more extreme cases
here
because white is totally undeveloped on
the queen side
and it's going to take him at least a
few turns to get things going in the
center
right and so because white is a little
bit
behind in development on the queen side
and doesn't have immediate central
counter play
that means this is going to be a really
really good version for black which is
why black has an advantage
if we jump back to our first game uh
here we see that
black is still slightly underdeveloped
on the queen side
but you know white is is not really
developed with this bishop either
and this was still you know a reasonably
good scenario here
for magnus so the answer is
a lot of the time it's actually going to
be a playable idea
it's not always going to be you know
better for white or you know black
conversely
uh as is the case here but if it's going
to be playable
you know that really just depends
on if you know the opponent has castled
if the opponent has committed to h6
and if your pieces are in reasonable
position to sort of support these kind
of attacking
ideas as they are in this case for
magnus
now i wanted to look at a third game for
you guys here
if we've got the time looks like we do
oops a little bit of a spoiler there
uh we have alexander morozevich
uh against ruslan palmariav
and this game i believe i know where
this game is from do i know where this
game is from
where's this game from uh this is from a
town memorial tournament in
russia so still classical chess
oh well great wolf i i think the night
or is sort of uh an
exception to this idea because the the
night or
lines where white plays g4 you actually
sort of just expect it right
like the night or is an opening where
white is you know already supposed to be
attacking on the king's side in many
many many lines
and so g4 kind of fits in there i'm
looking at cases
where it's kind of out of the blue kind
of unexpected
uh is the endgame class today yes so the
endgame class is also
right after this one here on youtube
yeah g4 and the sicilians is just always
going to be a thing well let's jump into
this game now as well
we have d4 knight f6 c4 e6
knight c3 bishop b4 queen c2 so even
in the classical nimzo indian these g4
ideas
can crop up we do have an early castles
by black
now knight f3 c5
we have d take c5 knight a6
and then at the time uh the move that
or morozevich played was actually a bit
of a novelty
it has been played a number of times now
but i think when he played it
it was a novelty and that move is the
slightly counter-intuitive
c6 uh the point being this pawn is sort
of dead anyways
and so morzevich is just sort of giving
it away
uh in order to force
black to sort of recapture with one of
the pawns rather than
you know more naturally than knight or
the bishop so we have c6
d takes c6 and now a3
is challenging this bishop bishop takes
c3
queen takes c3 knight c5
and from here white develops pretty
naturally with bishop e3
well maybe not supernaturally depending
on who you ask you know guarding
or blocking in this e pawn but in this
case it does make a lot of sense gaining
tempo
on the knight we have knight c to e4
queen e5
and now b5 threatening the queen side
and of course
what should white play in this position
is c6 a good move yeah c6 is a playable
move um
as with most lines in the nimzo indian
if black plays well white won't get an
advantage but that's just because chess
is draw
white definitely isn't worse after c6
chess king wants to play knight g5 and
then g4
and beltran just wants to play g4
immediately
and so uh the idea here is
actually just going to be the immediate
g4
if you want to take on b5 this is
perfectly fine as well uh i would not
advise going
queen takes b5 though as now it's
actually going to be
uh black with rapid development and sort
of you know an attack appearing out of
nowhere
maybe white is probably still fine
after queen takes b5 i'm not even sure
which of these moves is better
they both kind of look good you know
challenging this bishop let's just go
with natural development
this queen is probably coming back to e5
and
yeah i'm not sure from here maybe bishop
c6
and it's it's just going to be a game
you know g4 now is probably a bit too
late
as we have defended this night so i do
like
the immediate g4 by white this is going
to be
the best move here and in fact white is
already very very close
to winning and now this is definitely
slightly different circumstances
than what we had seen in the past
so why is it that white can play g4 here
when we see
that black hasn't actually committed to
this move h7
h6 well uh the reason for this
is the reason h7
h6 is sort of uh you know good for white
in cases where he wants to play h4 is
because the move g5 is now going to come
with a threat to the knight
as well as a threat to the h pawn and so
black isn't really going to be able
to deal with both of these threats if g5
is allowed to be played
now in this case rather than having the
threat of g
takes h6 after the move g5 we do have
this threat
of queen takes e4 so in fact here
white is sort of giving up the threat of
g takes h6 because black hasn't played
h6 yet
but he does have this threat of queen
takes e4 so it is going to be a very
very advantageous version still
and the fact of the matter is black
simply has no way of dealing with the
awkward placement of these knights
if you try something like knight d6 rook
d1 is immediately just picking up this
piece
if you try something like queen to d6
well now after g5
queen e5 95 let's say 98 for example
bishop g2 and this is sort of just dead
dead lost already
i guess we can take b5 we can take c6 uh
we can kind of do whatever we want here
things are going to get pretty pretty
nasty pretty quickly
uh so in the game uh panamariov
actually goes for the move c5 now the
move g5 is still quite strong
queen a5 check was his idea with the
move c5 but after b4
cb4 uh morzevic simply collects this
knight on f6
and is up a full piece kind of for
nothing
and he does go on to win this game very
very easily rook g1
g6 rick d1 we have takes
and the move c6 uh is played for a
second time in the game
it's a little bit unnecessary here but
still fun stuff
we have takes rook g4 takes takes
and now the idea of playing c6 was that
95 is coming with threat to the bishop
we still see knight takes c6 and
bishop g2 is a clever idea to
sort of indirectly defend this rook with
the counter threat of taking on e4
and after a few more moves this game was
resigned well i guess a few more moves
but up a piece is up a piece
right and here panamarioff uh simply
resigned
was watching it two times so glad glad
you're with us now keegan
uh hopefully you survived the two times
speed
uh okay so what happened in this game
well it actually turns out uh black sort
of fell into this opening prep
with this nice move c6 by white let's
see right here
actually no that was the second time c6
was played right here on move seven the
move c6
by morozevich and with this idea
uh morzevich got such a crushing
advantage
in the central placement of his queen
and his active pieces
that he was also able to launch this
early attack with g4
rather than castle so nowadays
everybody and their grandmothers play
the move b take c6
uh to support the center with a move
like d5
rather than d take c6 which is just
going to be a little bit loose
without this d-pawn here to control the
center
and to sort of block any attacks along
the open d file
from white and that's how we saw after a
few moves
knight c5 should be 3 94 queen e5
and now b5 walking in to the move
g4 when this open d file is actually
playing against black
rather than forum uh imagine if this
b-pawn we're on d5
and this game might be a slightly
different story
so as i said the conditions here were
slightly different
for g4 to be played but the idea
is kind of still the same the idea is
you want to play g5
with kind of two different threats in
this case the thread is to the knight on
f6 and the knight on e4 rather than to
the knight on f6 and the pawn on h6
and so because of that uh white got a
very very nice
attack in this game and was immediately
just sort of winning a piece
uh okay well with that in mind i think
we're going to
head on over to yet another game
uh this is one between two
[Music]
no i don't wanna do this one i wanna do
this one instead all right
do i wanna do this one instead i think i
wanna do this one instead
this one is a game between um i forgot
his first name but his last name is
matlikov he
is a russian player who actually peaked
well over 2700
i think somewhere around 27 30. i think
he has
worked with uh spidler a bit as his
second when svidler was
making the rounds in the candidates
tournament
uh and his opponent was famed english
grandmaster
david howe uh so let's see what happened
here
here we have the move c4 e6 knight c3
d5 d4 bishop e7 and so this time
we do still have another queen's game
declined but rather than the regozin or
the nimzo
that we saw uh the ideas once again are
going to be slightly different knight f3
maxim that's right i wanted to say i
wanted to say maxim actually but i just
couldn't couldn't come up with it
so maxum matlikov is his name bishop g5
h6 and once again after bishop h4
and castles we are starting to arrive at
a position
where you could envision uh the move g4
being playable
for white now the question is
do you want to play a move like g4
immediately
or should you sort of hold off on doing
these types
of shenanigans what do you guys think
here
it's quite possible he's a friend of
ginger gm
but i don't know uh i think they are
both
english grandmasters so it would make
sense
chess king likes the move rook g1
what do we think
so yeah you guys are sort of on the
right track um playing
g4 immediately here would actually be a
pretty serious mistake
um and the reason for that
is g5 isn't actually going to be all
that severe of a threat
uh you can imagine you know black plays
some passing move
if we play the move g5 all of a sudden
now the move knight e4 comes on the
board
and in fact you you actually aren't
threatening to take on h6
and this is sort of the the key issue
here is that g4
isn't coming with any kind of a threat
because g5 is going to be met very
nicely
by the move knight e4 when there's going
to be a very awkward pin
on this bishop so
uh after something like c6 white could
definitely consider taking and playing
the move h4
but you know black doesn't have to play
c6
black can play a little bit more
actively with stuff like d take c4
and these sorts of play uh this sort of
play is going to be a little bit slow
with white kind of coming back and then
coming forward when in fact
if you wanted to play like this you sort
of should have been doing it from uh
from here
and even here it doesn't make the most
sense
although i think it might be a playable
idea here
and it looks like this has never been
tried so if you want to find a novelty
play this position anyways uh
after bishop h4 castles g4 immediately
actually doesn't make the most sense
and so for that reason uh matlakov plays
the move e3 here which is just the main
move
now david hal plays knight e4 and also
excuse me let me explain why you're fg1
doesn't quite work either
once again if black sort of just passes
g4
still is not really coming with a severe
enough threat for example
d takes c4 uh well maybe not d64 let's
say b5 if you play the move g5
still 94 is going to be quite strong
well actually maybe not maybe rook g1
has has some ideas but we can
actually just take here and play a move
like b takes c4 and black is going to
have excellent compensation
for uh for this type of attack
although the more i look at it the the
less i actually hate it
uh but i do think white can sort of hold
out for a better version
here so rook g1 might be a bit too much
in fact
yeah the move c6 is a little bit silly
c5 once again
is going to be a better way to uh to
challenge things if you get caught up
trying to do things like this you're
going to sort of have your attention
diverted
by issues on the queen side
so rook g1 and g4 don't quite make as
much sense here
and you might be wondering well what
really
is different here and the difference is
going to be the awkwardness of this
bishop on h4 this is really the reason
why these ideas aren't working here if
you imagine
a different position where this bishop
is sort of
on you know let's say
c1 castles here even the move g4
uh probably isn't actually going to be
the best idea okay you can imagine
a move like this where black makes some
sort of nonchalant move
now all of a sudden the move g4 might
actually be well worth considering here
because this bishop's better placed our
center is a little bit more well
prepared to handle
these types of immediate attacks and uh
you can sort of launch it and attack on
the king's side
in in this manner uh okay so what
happened in the game let's get to it
shall we e3
knight e4 takes on e7 takes on e7
and now rook c1 uh rook c1 of course
just preparing to recapture this with
the rook
rather than the pawn maintaining the
structure and now after c6
let me ask you once again does the move
g4 make sense here
as i highlight random moves to offer
no type of hint does the move g4 make
sense
chess king says g4 looks good here
gyroslav is giving it
an exclamation point and yeah the move
g4
is is definitely a playable line and
that's what matlakov goes for
in this game uh
and now uh i guess we are running a
little bit short on time
so we'll go a little bit quickly here
howell simply develops his knight with
knight d7 now
h4 is the natural follow-up this is one
of those cases when playing g5
immediately
doesn't really make sense because knight
g5
there's simply nothing going on here you
know h4 we'll just take this knight
and black is very quickly ready to
defend
so h4 first we have e5 now in the game
uh david howell trying to counter attack
in the center but after cd5
we see takes takes takes on d5 and now
after g5
white does already have a pretty
significant advantage here
e4 this knight drops back to d2 and hal
feels the need to take on g5 notably
uh white is stopping the move h5 here
which definitely contributes
to his advantage queen h5 is now a key
move
g6 was uh black's choice
and now rather than queen h6 allowing
the move g4
uh matlakov simply takes on g5 and the
queen's come off the board
but what has white gained for his early
g4
well unfortunately black played well
enough not to get checkmated
but this g5 pawn is going to be a very
nasty thorn in black's side
and look for threats to this king to
sort of come later on
in any type of end game also notably
black has been forced to kind of weaken
this d5 pawn
and it's enough for a pretty significant
edge for white
in the game play continued for a while
f3 was great to open up this diagonal to
get at this pawn
bishop d3 as well king d2
and we have just an end game that's
matlikov managed to outplay his opponent
in
with pawns now rolling up the board
and in rapid fire fashion matlakov did
end up winning this game
with some nice uh nice end game
technique
picture of magnus well we showed
magnus's game first so i threw up a
picture of him
so what was the point of this game and
then i'll review
uh sort of some key points in the
lecture the point is
be on the lookout for g4 but don't be
super committed this idea
uh you're going to need a little bit of
help from your opponent if you want
these ideas to g4 to work of g4 to work
when are they going to work well they're
going to work when your opponent plays a
slightly slower style
with moves like c6 rather than
immediately trying to challenge the
center with moves like c5 if black is
playing very very quickly very actively
in the center
then your play on the king side is
simply not going to be fast enough to
challenge the play in the center
but when black plays a little bit more
slowly in the center trying to just
sort of develop slowly and naturally
taking advantage of the fact that things
are
sort of closed up that's when g4 can
become a really great attacking
idea as we saw in the four games we went
over
today uh
and that is sort of the key point of of
this game
not playing g4 here when uh black would
have very
active play immediately and white is not
creating substantial threats with g5
but playing g4 here when after black has
played c6
it takes a few turns for serious play in
the center to to really get going
giving white time to play moves like h4
and g5
opening things up uh now the point of
the lecture
all together is one i would love if you
guys
tried some of these fun g4 lines on your
own
in your own games i think that would be
really really fun to see more of this
type of game
because as it stands this is really
fairly uncommon
even though it's a perfectly playable
idea in many many positions
and we're seeing the top level players
actually employ it like magnus carlsen
in this recent tournament uh it still
remains sort of this underground idea
that i feel like a lot of people don't
know about and are sort of unprepared
for
so i would love to see more people
playing it but also maybe even more
importantly
you definitely need to be aware of this
idea as the other
side as the side with the black pieces
in these types of positions you
definitely don't want to be caught off
guard
by someone playing the move g4 as geary
was
in his game against magnus just
yesterday i believe
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this
lecture
up next i'm going to be teaching the end
game class we're going to be going over
a few end games actually from the same
tournament that we started with here
the legends of chess tournament uh
so hopefully you guys stick around and
check that one
out if you're watching the the youtube
replay that is
it for tonight i want to thank you guys
very very much
for joining me here tonight and i will
see
you next time